[Music]
you love movies but you really love bad
movies no one goes on and on like this
guy when he sees a movie he doesn't like
and you get obsessed with him is there
any movie that you've seen lately that
was bad and you like that reason no this
one was worse than I thought it even
could be and that was neat for speed
it was so bad that I was in awe and and
I lasted maybe 20 minutes and I had the
really yes and by the way I what's the
kid's name is Darden at great Aaron Paul
he's the nicest guy ever great on
Breaking Bad but he's so sweet he's
naturally sweet and then this movie's
playing a tough guy and here's the thing
that makes me nuts and made me nuts was
the fact that he succeeds through this
this Jesus guy and were supposed to root
for him yet he's driving cars 200 miles
per hour through cities other cars are
crashing people I know are dying it used
to be in movies when like you cause cars
to crash we'd see someone get out of the
car and look at it and go why what's
going on yeah to show that they were
okay they're not doing now in movies
they don't do that and so they think
cars swirl and hit and die Oh Mikey then
he's driving away and then like when
other people die gets upset that's like
you're going to order miles over a
bridge someone's gonna fly off it it's
gonna